Thank you. Hello. How is everyone doing? I
am I am actually superexcited to be here.
But I've also had very little sleep so it
might not show through. But, yeah. Thanks
for coming. And thanks to JSConf for inviting
me and thanks to everyone that has made this
event really awesome. It's super great to
be here.
And I wanted to kind of just take a quick
moment to say, like, happy anniversary, tenth
year of JSConf. Superexciting, but also a
little bit sad since they're gonna take a
little break. But let's stay positive and
be excited about the tenth year and I'm really
excited to see what happens next. There are
some amazing people that are involved in this
whole effort. So, I look forward to seeing
what they bring next. But also, happy birthday
to Node. I don't know if everyone knows that
this is ten years of Node. Whoo!
[ Applause ]
Ryan introduced Node here at JSConf in 2009.
Shoutout to Jenn Shiffer, 2009. Happy belated
birthday from I/O JS. I couldn't find the
Node.js Tweet that said happy birthday, so
I went with this one. I'm here to talk to
you about promises in Node Core. The Core
APIs in Node and what state they are in terms
of being promisified. And I want to start
with a little disclaim. I will try to make
as few puns as possible. I'm going for zero.
And technically I don't think this is a pun.
And if you are keeping track, mark of zero.
I'm Joe Sepi. My little Twitter handle's down
there. You can barely see it. But if you search,
you'll find me. I'm an open source engineer.
I have the great fortune of being paid to
work on open source exclusively pretty much.
And technically and in the community and as
a part of the Foundation. Why does my phone
keep buzzing? I told them, leave me alone.
Okay. It's not doing it. Anyway.
So, I'm superfortunate and it's great. I love
it. I work if a lovely company called IBM.
We make typewriters and we have we have a
cloud. But it's really just someone else's
computer. So, don't be fooled. Not to be confused
with how so, you know, IBM. This is my lovely
family.
[ Laughter ]
This is also my lovely family. This is what
I do in my spare time. That's Pat and Stella,
and this is what I really enjoy doing. I play
in another band, that's also Stella in the
background. That's me up there as well in
the back. And I occasionally play in a Misfits
cover band. So, funny story. All of this was
to lead up to, you know, karaoke tonight.
But then I realized that was my talk is after
official karaoke.
However, I am always open for karaoke. So,
if anyone wants to go, I'm here all week for
the TC39 meetings. Ping me. My DMs are open,
let's go do karaoke. Okay. Cool. So, I digress.
Which I do often if you know me.
I wanted to just quickly share a little bit
of personal context around Promises. I've
worked at a company called The New York Times
a few years ago. And pretty much everywhere
I've worked for the last I think almost every
job I've ever had I've done some form of developer
advocacy formally or informally.
And I started this weekly JavaScript thing.
Which I managed to do every single week. Largely
sourced by internal folks. Luckily at the
Times we had so many great people like Jeremy
and David Nolan and Mike and lots of great
people. But occasionally I would have some
outside folks come in and talk to us about
cool stuff. So, this is in like 2012? 2013?
Tom Hughes came in, Rebecca Murphey. Spike
came by and my old friend Dominik was there
too. So, Tom talked about sockets and streams
in Node. What's the date on this again? Yeah,
2012. And so, I mean, Node was around for
a few years. It was still pretty new, pretty
exciting. And the hockey stick had not really
happened yet. Rebecca came and we had kind
of an informal discussion, you know, a group
discussion. This was one of the things she
talked about.
Shoutout to yayQuery. I mean, does anyone
know yayQuery? All right? Do some research.
It's fantastic. Anyway. Spike came and talked
to us about Render which was this really cool
isomorphic framework where you could bring
backbone app that would be frontend and backend
with the same code. It was kind of revolutionary
at the same time. It was really cool. And
Dominik came in to talk to us about this little
spec he was working on.
And at the time there were a few libraries
that were implementing Promises. But everybody
kind of had their own flavor. And so, Dominik
was working on, you know, developing a spec
that would be something that the language
could implement. And fortunately, Dominik
continues to be amazing work in the spec space.
Thank you, Dominik. It was also a great opportunity
for me to say that wrote for the "New York
Times," which is pretty cool. I talked about
callback hell in JavaScripts. And how we're
working on it using, you know, the Promises
async flow.
And this looks bad, but it's not actually
that bad. It's fairly linear. But when you're
nesting asynchronous flow in a variety of
ways, they can get really, really, really
painful and hard to debug. And, you know,
I think it was one of the quiz questions last
night, you know? Which of these async functions
are gonna end first? If I'm not mistaken,
almost everyone got it wrong.
Then I went to work for a company called Behance
which was a lot of fun. And there were really
smart people there. And everything we did
there was kind of Promisebased and it kind
of blew my mind for a few weeks or months.
But once I got a hang of it, writing almost
all my code using Promises, it was just a
fantastic way to control your async flow.
And you may know that Ryan was here last year
talking about regrets in Node.
And one of the key things he talked about
was not sticking with Promises. And granted,
this is really early on, 2009 to 2010. He
removed them in February. And as he says in
the talk, you know, maybe it's okay that they
didn't remain in Promises. Because not having
the implementation in there allowed the community
to kind of work through what might be the
best implementation. There were a variety
of libraries like I said before, Q and R is
SVP doing their own implementations of promises.
And it allowed the community to find the right
abstraction and we could go from there. It's
a good model that I think we've used time
and again in JavaScript.
But as he said, Node's many async APIs are
aging pretty badly. And this is definitely
a pain point in writing Node which has a lot
of callbackbased APIs, obviously. Async is
at the core.
So, one tip, if you are really trying to get
your talk accepted at a conference is to reference
one of the organizers in your talk proposal.
I don't know if it worked or not, but I'm
here in front of you now. So, one of those
references is to this Tweet. And it really
was kind much funny, but sad. LOL at Node.js
Core modules for still using the callback
pattern. This is in November. And I have this
bad habit of maybe it's a good habit, actually
of finding something interesting that I would
like to hear a talk about and submitting it.
Whether I know a lot about it or not. But
this was really interesting to me and so I
submitted a talk about how, you know, where
we are and where we're trying to get to. And
how you may be able to help. And fortunately
for me, it got accepted. Here we are.
So, one of the responses is Myles who is superactive
in the Node space, in a variety of spaces.
I love Myles. And he shares with us that the
FS API already has an experimental promise
implementation. And this is one of the problems.
It's not maybe the prettiest because we needed
to figure out how to namespace, essentially,
Promise implementations of APIs. But he points
this out and people are pretty excited about
it. And he shares that, you know, unfortunately
there are only two that were implemented at
the time in late November. And it's FS and
DNS and they're experimental. Now, there are
some puns on these slides. But I did not make
them. So, I don't I still don't think they
count. Keep it zero, Donny. And then it was
also pointed out that there's a utility in
the framework that you can basically wrap
any callbackbased Node API using util.promisify.
As stated there, it's still a little bit horrible.
But it gets somewhere. Why was it taken out
and then has not been just like brought back
into Node? And this was something Matteo said
to me a couple of days ago at the Open JS
Collaborator Summit which happened just before
JSConf. Is that it's an insanely hard problem
that's been there forever. And that we've
never really been able to find a great way
to solve and find consensus on what the implementation
is. For a variety of reasons.
So, the big problem is that Promises were
primarily designed for browsers. And so, if
you have, you know, something go wrong in
your promise in a browser for a user, you're
only affecting one user, you know, one tab.
They might not even notice. They may think
why is my Facebook reply not showing up or
something? And they view the console, they
may see some sort of error. But it probably
doesn't even affect them that much in most
cases.
But if something happens on the server, it
could bring the whole server down. It likely
will. And that affects obviously way more
than one user, right? So, this is one of the
big problems, the challenges that we face
with Promises in Node Core. And here is an
example. So, we had a session at the collab
summit on this very topic and we kind of worked
through some of these things as a group.
And this is pretty basic pseudo code. But
the sum function call will anything, you know,
beyond that resolve will essentially get swallowed.
And so, you could have code like this in and
bunch of code after that, but if your promises
resolved, all of that code is essentially
it's run. But if you have any errors, you
have very little I think no way of actually
seeing what's going on there. Your app may
come down. You may have all sorts of problems.
But you may never know that that's the issue.
And then this is another example. Essentially
if you have a promise that never resolves
and the event loop finishes all of the things
that it needs to do, you just have this promise
kind of hanging out out there, you don't really
know that that's there because it never resolves
and it's sort of invisible as well.
So, essentially this is all a debugging nightmare,
right? But the great news is that there has
been progress. And things are happening. There's
a zero cost async stack traces were shipped
not that long ago. And so, that can help us
get some insight into some of these issues.
But here's another big one reason, right?
So, how do you promise event emitters that
don't resolve once? They may have multiple
events coming back, right? So, what do we
do there? Well, the and, you know, as I said
there are multiple responses. The tricky part
too is that some of the key things that the
core APIs use event emitter under the hood,
right? So, this is a daunting problem.
Well, the good news is, events.once, that
one's kind of easy to solve. And I can't remember
if there's a PR. It may have already landed
in Core. But events.on needs an async iterator.
This talk has been evolving minutebyminute,
hourbyhour. We had the collab summit Thursday
and Friday of last week and this Tweet came
through yesterday morning.
So, I'm like continually updating these slides.
And they're also my talk notes. So, if they
come up and I haven't actually implemented
a slide, don't blame me. I'm working on it.
But the great news is, there's a PR open by
Matteo to implement async iterator for the
event emitter. So, stuff is happening. It's
really, really exciting.
Sometimes this is thrown up as a bit of a
road block. And, you know, obviously we do
need to be considering performance and the
implementations that we're making. But I think
we need to make sure we balance them between
the developer experience and delivering on
what is, you know, a modern interface for
a modern platform, right?
So, like I'm kind of getting at, the good
news is that things are getting better and
progress is being made on a very ongoing basis.
Some APIs are already done. As I mentioned,
F S and DNS, events.once. There are a few
others that are already implemented. Some
PRs are open like the one we just looked at
for a second there. I have one I'm going to
open over the next few days that's around
crypto. So, things things are definitely happening.
And other development is in progress. And
when I say that, I mean, this is from November
of that Tweet about lol at Node Core to now,
there has been a real swell of activity.
And especially with the Summit session that
we had. Like the people are focused on this
when we asked for volunteers. There were,
you know, six or seven people that raised
their hands. And I'm trying to think about
this too from like a something of a project
management standpoint and helping list out
the APIs, see what state they're in. I'll
be opening some issues soon to catalog what
APIs still need to be done. And we can start
to really track this effort in a holistic
fashion.
So, we try to do everything in Node out in
the open. You know, through issues and comments
and PRs and such. And so, this is an issue
in the Summit repo for the recent Berlin Summit.
And so, as you can see here, one of the topics
that we talked about was unhandled rejections.
So, when like I showed earlier, if you resolve
your promise and you have a bunch of other
stuff happen and you get exceptions, how can
we handle that and surface these errors so
that you know where they're coming from?
We have a survey that we're working through,
if people are interested in. We're also if
I were able to scroll down on the screenshot,
there's a link to user feedback survey that's
I have been trying to get over the finish
line that would be more for end users, what
their experiences are, how they're managing
promises and give us some more insight into
what we may want to be considering in further
development here.
And then that bottom link there is the list
of all the APIs and some notes on the current
state of things.
So, as mentioned, there's a survey, primarily
focused for implementers as to what we think
would be the best way to handle these rejections.
This is that list of the APIs that I mentioned.
There are only 50 of them. And a bunch of
them are not relevant. Some of them are already
done. But, you know, we're trying to get a
real handle on the overall effort. But like
I said, the ground swell within the project
is real. People are focused on this. It's
taken a little bit of time to get there. There
are PRs open and there's work being done and
it's actually kind of exciting to think we
may have some more modern interfaces for those
Core APIs. The kind of call to action here
too is if you are at all interested, we always
welcome people to get involved.
I know sometimes working on Node Core can
be a little daunting. But it's not that bad.
You should talk to the folks involved, Joyee,
Fedor, any of the folks involved would be
happy to share with you. It is a strategic
initiative for the technical steering committee,
the TSE. Matteo is the champion. I'm trying
to help along with Ruben to Ruben Bridgewater
to spearhead these things. Myles is doing
work. Everybody is doing work on these things.
Benjamin is involved. A lot of people are
focused on this now. This is exciting.
This is one of those slides that I should
have updated, but I haven't filed that initial
PR. Once I did, there would be next to Matteo's
name a link to catalog where we are. And I
promise you that we will resolve this problem.
All right?
[ Applause ]